bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission où nous allons être cette fois
ci 2 à grogner
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du rebond économique ou pas
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches quelle
reprise économique pour l'après qu'ovide
19 à quoi peut-on s'attendre
faut-il changer de modèle de croissance
ce sont les questions qui vont nous
occuper dans cette émission et en
deuxième partie vous entendrez
l'éclairage de charles gave économistes
et et ses listes mais d'abord olivier on
va commencer avec ses prévisions de la
deutsche bank pour la zone euro en date
du 6 août dernier
selon elle le rebond post confinement a
été plus fort que prévu dans la zone
euro l'institution table désormais sur
une contraction de l'économie de 8,6
pour cent contre 12 % initialement
du côté à du pib mondial il devrait
chuter de 4 5% au lieu de six pour cent
et plus de son côté le fait ni penche
pour une récession mondiale de 4,9 pour
cent en 2020 d'après ses estimations du
mois de juin dernier alors olivier on
sait que critiquer soient elles ces
indicateurs on voit après révision de la
deutsche bank que les deux institutions
à rêves
finalement à peu près aux mêmes
estimations pour autant est-ce qu'on
peut réellement encore aujourd'hui
mesurer l'impact de la crise du côté de
19 bien sûr que non puisqu'on vient de
rentrer qu'on n'a pas encore je dirais
les effets réellement économies qu'on a
on a été dans l'oeil du cyclone cet été
en fait donc dans l'oeil du cyclone les
vans calme tout va bien et on a on a eu
une petite une petit un petit rebond de
la consommation qui était bien normal
après la chute qui avait eu pendant le
confinement
d'autant plus que comme les gens ne
pouvaient pas circuler était bien obligé
de rester sur place ne pouvait pas
partir à l'étranger
donc ça a fait un petit rebond ok
maintenant les les mesures vont prendre
pour une une certaine partie prendre fin
et donc on va rentrer vraiment dans le
vif du sujet maintenant
donc si vous voulez les prévisions que
peuvent faire le fmi ou la deutsche bank
je dirais ccc des prévisions au doigt
mouillé
et ça n'a pas grande valeur donc qu'ils
vont les réviser à la fin du mois de
septembre la fin du mois d'octobre à la
fin du mois de novembre on aura un
chiffre qui sera bien différent de celui
qui est aujourd'hui donc ça n'a pas
grand intérêt
mais il faut bien quand même payer
quelques analystes pour faire le boulot
ça fera moins de chômage chez mieux oui
mais justement à quai la reprise
économique s'attendre en v ou en w
les économistes ont parfois du mal à
accorder leurs violons
tour d'horizon avec le tiroir-caisse
d'antenne passe difficile pour les
économistes de dresser nos profits qu de
gars reprise qui nous attend plusieurs
possibilités
plusieurs hypothèses petit alphabet de
la reprise économique
la reprise en v c'est le profil de
rebond le plus utopique une économie
chute brutalement suite à un choc comme
le co vide puis remonte aussi rapidement
pour immédiatement se stabiliser durant
la crise actuelle cela pourrait être le
cas grâce à la limitation de la chute
des revenus liés au chômage partiel et
ils épargnent en a deux côtés pendant le
confinement
un scénario un peu bisounours qui avait
néanmoins déjà eu lieu lors de la
récession de 1954 aux états unis
la reprise en plus d'un scénario un peu
proche d'user sauf que l'économie
stagnerait un niveau pas quelques temps
avant de retrouver ses niveaux d'avant
crise ce serait notamment à cause de
certains secteurs plus lent a redémarré
comme le tourisme
un scénario espéré par de nombreux pays
actuellement dont la france
la représente w ou en double creux etc
table simplement sur une deuxième vague
de nouvelles mesures de confinement est
donc une rechute de l'économie après une
première reprise pour finalement
retrouver son niveau initial
un peu plus tard et ce ne sont là que
quelques uns des nombreux scénarios
on aurait également pu parler du
scénario en l an le scénario catastrophe
qui voit d'économie ne jamais remonter
et la crise perdurer indéfiniment
reste maintenant à savoir quel scénario
se confirmera et comment notre économie
et beaumont dira si elle rebondit alors
ils viennent sans que vous vous penchez
annie pour lever ni pour le w mais
plutôt pour les aides
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste une reprise en z non mais
c'est un peu c'est une moquerie mais
c'est si vous voulez tout c'est tous ces
débats sur la forme de la reprise en
fait c'est toujours vécu ou est là parce
que c'est ces logiciels qu'on a depuis
des années et des années
je vois que vous avez été obligé de
remonter à 54 aux états unis donc voyez
bien que on a on a toujours finalement
les mêmes profils et est donc je disais
pourquoi pas on z parce que en fait
n'avait pas énormément de croissance
même très peu de croissance
avant le coc vide je vous rappelle quand
même que le quatrième trimestre en dans
beaucoup de pays était déjà en récession
donc avant le coc vide
donc on était bien dans quelque chose
qui qui n'a été le co vide n'a été qu'un
catalyseur en fait de ce qui s'est passé
et donc la récession elle était là avant
et donc je disais en fait on descente
deux étages et puis on reprend
notre nom croissance pendant les années
à venir et je m'amuse beaucoup de voir
les prévisions de monsieur bruno le
maire qui nous annonce que en 2022
finalement on aura tout effacer et qu'on
reprendra là la course continue elle de
croissance qu'on a jamais eu avant et je
vois pas pourquoi on l'aurait après en
2022 avec la dette qu'on est en train de
se mettre sur le dos et avec
l'incapacité et l'incompétence de nos
dirigeants
merci à vous qu'on les vit on passe tout
de suite à la deuxième partie de cette
émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec charles gave bonjour chers le gars
vous êtes économiste et ses listes merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
bienvenue monsieur galles on l'a vu
notamment dans le tiroir qhd les
différentes formes de reprise reprise en
v reprise en w olivier nous parlait tout
à l'heure de la reprise en z selon vous
quelle forme pourrait prendre la courbe
d'europe la reprise économique et quel
est le scénario le plus probable
j'écoutais ça m'intéresse beaucoup parce
que vous avez l'air de penser que les
économies sont capables de prévoir
l'avenir les économistes lambeaux leur
boulot c'est pas de prébende à venir
c'est d'expliquer ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est l'économie donnait une
branche des mathématiques ni une branche
de l'astrologie c'est une branche de la
logique donc ce que je vais essayer de
vous dire c'est que la croissance
économique dépend d'une chose est une
seule c'est les entrepreneurs les
entrepreneurs que ce que vous avez en
france ils ont une marge brute
d'autofinancement enquête au plus bas et
qui vient de s'écrouler encore à nouveau
donc si vous voulez beaucourt bola elles
sont très mignonne mais ça ne veut
strictement rien dire la réalité si vous
voulez ça fait à peu près trente ans que
la croissance structurelle en france
baisse et donc elle va continuer à être
au mieux médiocre et au pire
catastrophique corolla d'après l'oeuvre
le scénario qu'on peut voir donc tout ça
c'est pas
c'est pas bien intéressant parce que par
exemple au milieu le pib français le pib
allemand et la même croissance depuis
1997 mais nous là toute la croissance du
pib vient de la croissance du poids de
l'état dans l'économie et le secteur
privé n'a cessé de se contracter
le en allemagne le poids des cas de
l'état dans l'économie restait à plate
et 97 et toute la croissance est ni de
secteur privé donc si je devais faire à
paris je dirais qu'il est probable que
l'allemagne va mieux s'en sortir que
nous il s'est à peu en train de tout ce
que je peux dire mais tant que l'on
continue aujourd'hui j'imagine que
compte tenu de la crise le poids de
l'état dans l'économie doit passer les
60 % c'est-à-dire qu'on a largement
dépassé par exemple on est très très au
dessus de la chine par exemple
donc tout ça n'est pas sérieux si vous
voulez parler de croissance quand on
prend toutes les mesures qu'il faut pour
que les entrepreneurs ne gagne pas
d'argent
j'ai un peu pas bien sérieux olivier
monsieur gamme l'audit la croissance
économique dépend être des entrepreneurs
et cette crise avait tout de même
particulière de nombreuses économies ont
été à l'arrêt pendant plusieurs semaines
il ya un climat encore aujourd'hui qui
est tout de même très incertain
la suite elle dépend aussi énormément de
la situation sanitaire
non mais la suite est bien sûr que la
halle et la situation sanitaire compte
si vous si demain vous arrêter à nouveau
l'économie comme ça a été fait pendant
deux mois
vous allez avoir forcément une
une aggravation de la chute mais ce que
je vous disais c'est qu'il faut pas
mettre non plus tout le tout sur le dos
du coc vide
ça fait des années et des années qu'on
fait n'importe quoi aux économiquement
et donc ça fait des années et des années
qu'on a en effet pas de croissance c'est
ce que je vous disais on était quand
même en récession
sur le dernier trimestre avant le coc
vide donc qu'on nous met pas tout sur le
dos du coc vivent donc ça ne ça n'est
pas que l'aspect sanitaire qu'il faut
aller regarder c'est le reste c'est la
manière dont on est dirigé depuis des
années le coc vite j'ai eu certains
c'est un révélateur
mais ça n'est pas un phénomène durable
c'est mettons c'est comme un tremblement
de terre quelque chose comme ça ça
montre à quel point nous sommes nous et
à sang à la fois en particulier notre
exagérément gros et du coup complètement
inefficace le problème pour qui la
croissance en france il faudrait que
l'état cesse d'être obèse et redevienne
efficace et aujourd'hui le coc vide
à ma connaissance il a plutôt fait
monter encore la taille de l'état et qui
plus est à cause du bolide on ne rajoute
une couche de réglementation
extravagantes par exemple surtout l'oeil
sur tout ce qui économise verte et
cetera temps moi je veux bien tout ce
qu'on veut mais si on continue à mettre
sans arrêt du poids sur le dos de l'âne
à un moment il va avoir le dos brisé
puis c'est tout de nombreux pays ont
récemment présenté à leurs plans de
relance en c'est le cas de la france de
l'allemagne
est ce qu'à fait qu'avec ces instruments
on est capable de revenir au niveau
d'avant la crise mais écoutez les plans
de relance j'ai commencé ma carrière en
71 ans 73 on a une récession
épouvantable à cause du pétrole et on
doit être à peu près au 20e plan de
relance en france
si l'état était capable de relancer
l'économie la france celle près il plus
développés du monde parce que depuis à
peu près 50 ans on passe d'une relance à
l'autre des bienfaits de ses relances et
toujours de faire monter le poids de
l'aide d'amis et d'augmenter les
réglementations donc ce dont on a besoin
c'est d'une baisse du poids de l'état
dans grosso modo il faudrait à la place
il faudrait simplement baisser le poids
de l'état baisser le poids de baisser le
poids des impôts sur les français et là
on aura une chance mais a cédé plus de
vidéos si vous il faut faire monter il
faut prendre il faut faire baisser les
impôts sur ceux qui prennent des risques
il faut il faut c'est pas difficile
savez la rentabilité iliad et pour
qu'une économie croise il faut que ceux
qui prennent des risques gagne plus
d'argent que ceux qui en prennent pas or
ça fait à peu près 30 ans qu'en france
le meilleur investissement c'était
d'acheter une obligation d'état français
qui sait mieux que la bourse de paris
sur les cinq dernières années les dix
dernières années les 15 dernières années
les vingt dernières années et un en
france le risque est pénalisé bos lui
demande c'est qu'on cesse de martyriser
c'était pas des riches c'est tout je
demande peut pas grand chose
olivier vous allez réagir à ce qu'a dit
charles gave mais d'abord on va marquer
une courte pause et on revient dans un
instant
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez à quelle reprise économique
s'attendre après la crise du côté de 19
on en discute avec olivier bien sûr et
charles gave économistes et essayiste
alain ollivier juste avant la pause
monsieur gallo disait qu'il fallait
baisser le poids de l'état pour relancer
l'économie en quelque sorte est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui mais ça
n'arrivera pas parce que aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que fait l'état ils continuent
à s'endetter je voulais dit cent fois
ici que de la dette
c'est de l'impôt futur et donc les
impôts ne vont pas baisser comme le
monde charles et ils vont plutôt monter
et bien que monsieur gentil mais ils
peuvent vous garantir tout ce qui est
tout ce qu'ils veulent ils vous
garantissez aussi qu'avec l'euro on
allait plus avoir de chômage et on
allait avoir de la croissance bon
c'était garantie mais sauf que c'est pas
arrivé donc
et là ça sera la même chose on ne peut
pas alors si vous ne réduisez pas le
train de vie au global de l'état eh bien
vous savez que quand vous vous endettez
ça sera qui pour rembourser nous donc
les impôts donc vous aurez des
augmentations d'impôts alors après sous
quelle forme j'en sais rien est ce que
ça sera des taxes est ce que ça sera de
l'impôt j'en sais rien non plus mais de
toute façon y viendrons vous prendre
votre argent dans votre portefeuille
parce que ils n'ont pas le choix c'est
l'autre choix l'autre alternative c'est
de réduire les dépenses
malheureusement comme ils ne veulent pas
le faire
eh bien on continuera à avoir des impôts
alors messieurs un mot sur ces chiffres
il ya tout de même des pays qui ont
montré à des signes de reprise c'est le
cas de la france selon une étude du
boston consulting group tâter à de fin
juillet le pays a connu le plus fort
rebond économique après le confinement
elle est même qualifiée de je cite
maillot jaune du rebond par le directeur
du cabinet même chose pour la chine qui
selon l'étude vrai je cite toujours
retrouver son niveau à d'activité preco
vie de monsieur gamme olivier nous
disait tout à l'heure que on l'avait été
dans l'oeil du cyclone cet été
et donc ce petit rebond était normale
mais est ce qu'on peut vraiment voir ça
comme de réels signes de reprise vous
savez je vais vous dire un truc tout ça
pour accepter la france qui avait eu le
le taux de baisse le plus forme
oui oui et alors s'élançant ce que
l'économie s'était le plus jamais les
noms donc on ne répond plus performent
pas ce qui m'intéresse et où on est par
rapport aux en était avant je suis
persuadé qu'on est plus bas qu elle est
l allemagne par exemple savez une action
qui passe de 100 à 50 et qui remonte
elle a baissé de 50%
et si elle remonte de 50 à 75 la montée
de 50% mais vous êtes toujours en baisse
de 25 94 quelque part on est en baisse
de 6 sur le plus haut ça et les chiffres
que vous donne les différents bureaux
d'études
d'abord je vous dis ils ont ça veut rien
parce que vous avez les choses qui sont
en train de se développer donc ne
comptez pas sur sur leur force de
prévisions ils sont incapables en
général de faire une prévision de ce qui
s'est déjà passé de faire un bon calcul
de ce qui s'est déjà passé leur
demandait pas de d'avoir des prévisions
correct et en plus je rappellerai au
boston consulting group que le maillot
du meilleur grimpeur c'est le maillot à
pois c'est pas le maillot jaune olivier
on est dans une économie ouverte et de
nombreux pays qui sont dépendants du
tourisme des importations et des
exportations
de toute façon la reprise économique
elle est indissociable d'un retour à la
normale de l'aide de la situation mais
là on n'a pas de retour à la normale
vous avez quand quand vous obligé
et
tout le monde a faim quand vous les
empêcher de voyager quand vous leur
coller un masque sur la tête
comment voulez vous que vous ayez un
retour à la normale vous n'avez pas de
retour à la normale est temps que ça
sera comme ça vous n'aurez pas de retour
à la normale et en plus si vous voulez
si vous comptez sur la la confiance des
gens pour reconsommera et consommer ce
qu'ils ont fait en épargne il faudrait
qu'on ait des gens qui ceux qui dirigent
et qui dirige réellement aujourd'hui si
vous êtes dans un avion et que vous
voyez un type complètement bourrés qui
ne s'est pas piloter vous aurez pas
confiance donc je suis désolé
aujourd'hui on est dans ce cas là on est
avec des gens qui ne savent pas piloter
et on lord et on nous demande d'avoir
confiance et dépenser notre argent
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'on a de
grandes chances de se retrouver au
chômage
donc non évidemment non les entreprises
françaises leurs caractéristiques par
rapport à toutes les entreprises vous
parle pas des industries du cac 40 que
les entreprises françaises n'ont pas de
fonds propres donc elles sont incapables
de prendre un coup dans les dents et
donc il y en a tout un tas qui vont
aller au tapis mais et c'est cette
entreprise là qui font 90 % des emplois
en france entrée par des entreprises de
moins de 10 personnes donc mais de quoi
parle t-on quoi c'est de la folie
je prie je sais mais je sais même pas de
quoi ils parlent je trouve qu'ils sont
en plein en plein déni c'est une
histoire que je sais pas de quoi ils
parlent
ils ont ils ont jamais ils n'ont pas été
visités des entreprises j'ai pas dans le
gers ou dans la région d'avignon où j'en
sais rien où il ya des types qui sont à
l'agonie
ils connaissent pas les petits hôtels
les hôtels et les restaurants
c'est un désastre c'est vraiment ça
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
sortez un peu et que vous allez voir
êtes vous allé discuter avec des
restaurateurs
le restaurateur aujourd'hui qui
cherchent un crédit c'est ce qui se
passe il va il va dans une banque qui
demande un crédit même une banque avec
laquelle il travaille depuis 20 ans et
la personne lui répond ah bah non on a
interdiction par là la direction de
prêter au restaurant et au secteur de
l'hôtellerie
parce que c'est un secteur sinistré donc
comment voulez vous qu'ils fassent
vous allez avoir je vous dis on a eu
l'oeil du cyclone dont qui s'est rien
passé pendant cet été parce que les gens
sont restés sur place il ya eu un tout
petit peu un minimum d'activité donc là
on se glorifie de ça et on fait des
prévisions comme quoi en 2022 on aura
réglé problème non parce que vous allez
avoir un tas de société qui jusqu'à
présent avaient pu résister parce que en
fait c'était l'état qui avait pris en
charge les salaires donc il n'avait plus
de visas et plus de charges pendant un
petit moment où mehlis avait pas de
chiffre d'affaires non plus à mettre en
face
sauf que là ils vont être obligés de les
reprendre
ils vont être obligés de les payer et là
je vous le dis vous allez avoir une
vague de mises au chômage importante
vous allez avoir une vague de sociétés
qui vont faire faillite et faut pas me
dire que on va tranquillement finir
l'année avec de la croissance c'est
ridicule pour terminer une réaction
peut-être à ces mots de la patronne du
fmi c'était le 9 9 septembre dernier
lors d'une visioconférence pour le forum
économique mondial je suit le travail
affaire nécessite une grande attention à
ce qui serait le moteur de la
productivité de demain c'est quoi le
moteur de la productivité de demain
selon vos charles gave à la la la
productivité vous savez il faut que tu
expliquer à vos auditeurs
c'est ce que les gens produisent à
partir des capitales du monde qui l'on
rend disponible
donc grosso modo vous voulez que les
gens investissent pour faire des
augmentations de productivité alors
qu'ils gagnent pas d'argent
le moteur de la productivité de demain
comme c'était celui d'hier ou
d'avant-hier et de toujours c'est de
laisser les entrepreneurs libres encore
une fois il n'y a pas de croissance sans
entrepreneurs et si vous empêchez les
entrepreneurs de gagner de l'argent là
productivité de baisse les gens pauvres
deviennent plus pauvres parce que le
coude
ils élèvent leurs patrons peuvent pas
les augmenter et donc encore une fois si
vous voulez on agit des mots il faut que
la productivité monte et en même temps
on fait exactement le contraire je crois
que c'était bossuet qui disait dieu se
rit des sommes qu'ils chérissent les
causes de ce qu'ils font ils créent des
catastrophes
on a un gouvernement qui fait de la
redistribution qui fait du social et qui
empêchent la croissance de ce fait et
vous parlez de productivité mes deux
compagnons c'est n'importe quoi laisser
à les entrepreneurs libres ce sera le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup cher le
gars d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans cette émission je rappelle que vous
êtes économiste et essayiste olivier on
passe à nous aux questions cash
merci charme et comme chaque semaine
olivier delamarche répond aux questions
que vous lui posez voici celle à dax où
le plan de relance est financée à 40 %
par l'europe jean castex et bruno le
maire assure avec il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation d'impôts du coup les 60%
restants ils les trouvent ou et bien
dans les impôts c'est ce que je vous ai
dis hein
à l'avant avec avec charles gave
en effet vous avez une augmentation
énorme de la bête dans tous les pays
européens d'ailleurs sauf ceux qui sont
bien arrangées sur le plan nous je vous
rappelle qu'on va récupérer 40 milliards
mais qu'on va en payer 100 donc le
résultat est négatif si je sais bien
faire encore des calculs simples
important mais on nous vend quand même
ce plan de relance européen alors que
nous payons ce plan de relance européen
et en est c'est pas positif pour nous et
donc je vous dis la différence elle se
trouvera dans vos poches
donc dans les impôts et même si vous
dise le contraire mais c'est habituel
combien de fois vous avez entendu des
politiques vous dire non non les impôts
ne monteront pas et combien de fois ils
ont monté derrière donc
bah si une fois de plus merci olivier
merci de votre fidélité c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi en
attendant n'oubliez pas de poser vos
questions à olivier delamarche sur les
réseaux sociaux ou en commentaire des
vidéos on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine et on se quitte avec votre
dernier mot olivier et bien il ya eu il
ya quelques années
z comme zorro là ça sera à z comme
reprises